-Our first guest tonight is
an Emmy Award-winning comedian,
who is in his record-breaking
20th season on
"Saturday Night Live."
The show returns live on
NBC and Peacock this Saturday
with host Aubrey Plaza
and musical guest Sam Smith.
Welcome back to the show
the one, the only
Kenan Thompson, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Hello, my friend.
-Wassup?!
-So, 20 seasons, Kenan.
-Is that not crazy?
-It's crazy.
I don't know
what to do with that.
-Yeah.
You're coming up on
as many years in this building
as out of this building.
-Yeah. It's -- Like, at this
point, the show is 48 years old.
-Yeah.
-I've been there for 20.
You know what I mean?
-Yeah, exactly.
-It is insane to me,
because "SNL" was --
you know, it was everything
growing up, and then --
-At the 50th anniversary
of "SNL,"
they'll do a montage
of through the years.
It could just be you.
-It's going to be a lot of me.
That's wild to me, so, yeah.
-Now, it's a trip, 'cause you
were how old when you started?
24 years old?
-25, yeah.
-25 years old.
And, at the same time, you came
in as a very young person,
but you were also this
accomplished sketch actor.
So I think --
-Yes, I was. Yes, I was.
-You know what I mean? Like...
[ Cheers and applause ]
-And why I say that is,
it's a full 20.
Like a lot -- I mean, I feel
like the first three years
I was there,
if you squeezed it all together,
would be like
two months of sketches,
whereas you were
so useful immediately
and so good at it immediately,
you were a big, important
cog in the machine
from the jump.
-Thank you, man.
I mean, it's a lot of work,
but, you know,
that's what we came there to do?
Question mark.
-Yeah.
Now, I'm very happy to say
that I am, of course,
not the only one who agrees
about your incredible talent.
And you just got this
over in Hollywood,
the Hollywood Walk of Fame.
-Oh, look at that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-There you go.
Now, how was the ceremony?
I know our friends
Leslie Jones, J.B. Smoove
were out there for you.
-Yes, and my good buddy
Josh Server.
They all spoke from the heart,
and it was a beautiful, warm,
I think, August day.
-Oh, that's -- Yeah.
-In Los -- Yeah.
Yeah, 'cause that is --
You are -- You know, for people
that haven't been there,
it's also still a full street.
-Yes, it is a full
Hollywood Boulevard.
-So a hot August day in
Los Angeles.
-Yeah, with a whole lot of,
"Hey, Kenan!"
from across the street.
And, you know, it was
a very touching day, you know?
-They say that you're
the easiest to recognize
when you're kneeling next to
a star with your name on it.
-1,000%, yeah.
-Did you check to see what
the adjacent stars were?
That's the part that is
always interesting to me.
-Crazy enough, I saw an "L-O,"
'cause the carpet
was covering one,
and then I saw, like, an "L-S."
So I couldn't see the full name.
I was like,
"Is that Lorne Michaels?"
And I'm right next to
Lorne Michaels.
-Really? You're on the
Lorne Michaels block.
-Like, literally,
like, touching stars.
It's...
-And you know he made sure
he got the best part
of Hollywood Boulevard.
-1,000%.
Yeah, no, we are actually
further down the street
than actual concrete
handprints.
And it was funny --
when I told Leslie that,
she's like, "Why are you all
the way down here?"
-Leslie is like, "I'm going to
give my speech down there
if you want to come down,
and then we'll walk back
to your star."
Hey, another cool thing
happened this year
when Keke Palmer
was on the show...
-Whew!
-..and you guys did
a "Kenan & Kel" sketch,
and Kel showed up.
-Yes.
-And this just --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Amazing.
Look, it looks like --
Does that not look like '96?
-Yeah.
Everyone is aging very well.
That black is not cracking.
-No.
If you showed a Nickelodeon show
with white people from 1996,
it would be -- the audience
would have screamed.
-You said it.
[ Laughter ]
-But this was --
Was this Keke's idea?
-That was a very special,
special week, because --
Yes, it was Keke's idea.
She told me about it on Monday
and she was like,
"I got an idea for the show" --
"Kenan and Kelly."
And I was like, "Say no more.
Like, I get it 1,000%."
And I was trying to figure out
how to make, you know,
Nickelodeon appealing for
the "SNL" audience.
You know what I mean?
Because it's like child
kind of network or whatever,
and this is adult humor.
And this was
the first time I thought
we would be able to
figure that out.
So we did,
and then, like, you know,
her tag line,
you know, was just, like,
off from Kel's tag line,
"Oh, here it goes."
So, then we thought like,
what's the most
nonsensical kind of thing
she could say
that is still kind of real?
And we came up with
"Uh-oh, here comes the bus."
And by the time
she did it the third time,
it was just, like,
oh, priceless.
-Everybody here
is really cast --
I do also want to
point out, Mikey Day --
perfect in that world.
Like, in another world,
Mikey Day is definitely on
a Nickelodeon show.
-1,000%.
Or headed towards one now.
But, yeah, Mikey playing
Dan Fishman was great.
And then Kel came in
and just destroyed it.
You know what I mean?
It was very special.
-It's a really cool thing,
which I recognize
we're talking about this --
usually, the people on the show,
when the host comes in,
they're like, "Oh, I have
this idea from this thing
I saw you in years ago."
This is the first time
I've heard about a host
coming in and saying,
"I want to do something"...
-From your past. Yeah, yeah.
-Yeah, from your past.
-Right. Yeah.
-But I think it speaks --
Again, it speaks
to the remarkable sense
not just that you've
been on "SNL" for 20 years,
but you had this
real career beforehand.
-Yeah, man, it's been a crazy
kind of whirlwind experience.
I don't really know, like, how
to put it in words, necessarily,
but I am very grateful,
because it was emotional
even for, like, the crew.
You know what I mean?
Like, "This brings me back
to my childhood."
Like, everybody was saying that.
And walking onto that set
in a place
that, you know,
I've been knowing for 20 years
is something else.
You know what I mean?
It was such
a blast from the past.
It was amazing.
So I'm beyond blessed.
-You've also been there so long,
one of the things --
You know, I went through it,
as well.
The longer you are there,
the more you have to say
goodbye to people.
You said goodbye to the great
Cecily Strong.
Left the show
the Christmas show.
And there you are with
Austin Butler.
-One time for Cecily.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It must be emotional
when people leave.
I remember my last show,
you couldn't stop crying.
Do you remember that?
You were just sobbing.
-Yeah. I mean,
everybody was just, like --
couldn't move when you left.
It was unbelievable. I remember.
I'm laughing about it now only
because it's been so long.
-Hey, I got a lot more to
ask you.
Will you stick around?
-Absolutely.
-We'll be right back
with more from the great
Kenan Thompson, everybody.